Please can I have some advice for dealing with poor leaders at work they have
little respect for,
and the question as a subordinate,
how do you handle a leader who leads from a place of ego
and isn't transparent with information?
Yeah,
so these were a couple of questions actually that I got and I just kind of
bunched them together because my answer's going to be very similar for each of
them.
And it's actually very similar to a situation that I'm dealing with right now.
The guy that I'm helping out.
And I wrote,
um,
something to him recently.
And what happened was he's in a situation where a leader had come in that didn't
have the knowledge inside the industry they were working in.
So you came from another industry,
got put into a leadership position and that guy,
that new leader was resisting change and not giving support to the new
procedures that the guy who was coaching was trying to implement.
So he was kind of,
you know,
at a loss for what to do.
You know you've got this new manager that's coming in that's inexperienced and
Eva and the Guy I'm coaching obviously doesn't respect him because he doesn't
have a lot of knowledge in this industry.
And so here's the advice I gave him.
I said,
you need to set this up to make the new manager look good.
Make some adjustments to the words you are choosing,
the tack you are taking and the focus you are using to ensure that your changes
make him look good,
not bad.
Now let's just so counterintuitive for people.
It's so counterintuitive cause they get to a person that's above them and the
chain of command that doesn't know as much as them,
that's not as smart as them and what do they want to do?
They want to bring them down.
They want to prove to everybody that they're better.
I'm better than that guy.
They'd either war on that guy.
I deserve that guy's job.
That's what everybody's instinct is to do and it's wrong.
It's wrong.
Somehow let the ideas come from him or make him the approver or the driver of
some of the s aspects that he can handle.
So I'm actually saying,
go out of your way to make this easier for this guy.
Make him look good.
Give him credit.
It's your ego that wants to pull him down.
Put your ego in check,
help him without being condescending or acting like you know more than him.
He shouldn't even know you are helping him.
Have you ever been,
this is so fun to do is when,
you know,
Echo doesn't know this section of the equipment.
So I don't say,
Hey,
since you don't know this,
um,
all teach it to you,
right?
This condescending tone of,
you know,
but instead of like,
hey,
have you ever seen the way this one works?
I know your eye.
Have you ever seen this specific equipment?
Because the way it works,
it's a little bit different than,
than some of the other ones is you got to do this,
this,
and this.
And you can sit back and you can accept that knowledge without feeling like you
don't know it.
Right?
So I'm teaching you,
but I'm doing it in a clandestine manner.
And that's what we're trying to do because we're trying to build,
we're trying to do,
we're trying to build a relationship here.
That's what we're trying to do.
We're trying to build a relationship.
And if I go,
since you don't know how to use this,
I'll show you now what does that do?
Puts you on the defensive,
makes you,
um,
uh,
considered me to be a threat.
Now I'm threatening and that's not good.
He should even know you are helping him respect what he does and show him that
you respect it.
So,
hey,
you know,
I know this is,
you probably haven't been down in the weeds on this type of gear in a while,
but hey,
this is the way,
you know what I'm saying?
Like you actually,
I actually respect the fact that you're up top in charge and I'm just a front
line guy.
But here's how you do this.
If you ever had to,
you know what I mean?
Just downplay what he doesn't know and subtly help him to learn it.
Right.
You know,
you probably wouldn't ever have to do this,
this,
this new equipment over here.
I mean,
I know was a little bit below your level.
Here's how it works.
If you ever needed it,
boom.
You know what I mean?
Not like you don't know how to do this right?
I do.
You know,
you don't want an adversarial relationship with this new leader.
You want him to support and help you.
He will do that.
If you are making him look good.
This is so easy,
man.
This is so easy and so hard because everybody's ego will get in the way.
Everybody's Eagle will get in the way.
Extreme ownership often requires covert and clandestine indirect actions.
So all these things that I'm talking about helping the guy without him knowing,
um,
uh,
letting him take credit for ideas without him knowing
all these little aspects,
they're indirect actions.
They're not going head to head.
It's like Jujitsu.
It's Jujitsu all the time.
Everything's Jujitsu.
You don't want to,
if you know,
I'm going to do an arm bar,
I am not going to get the arm bar right.
You're going to defend that.
So I have to go take indirect actions and set things up and take my time and be
clandestine and covert.
This is chess,
not checkers.
This is where you need to master your ability to influence,
which as we talked about a couple podcasts ago,
is actually manipulation.
I'm manipulating this guy to think that he's got something over me.
I'm inflating his ego while I'm putting my ego in check.
I'm making him feel like he's even better and that makes him feel good.
It makes him want to support me because I make him look good.
This is,
this is just basic.
If you do this wrong,
the new manager will resist you at every turn.
If you do this right,
he will be your biggest supporter.
Now,
this is the same thing with leaders that you quote unquote don't respect.
First of all,
there should be something that you respect about everybody.
Everybody that you meet,
you should have some kind of respect for them.
And by the way,
if you don't respect someone,
what is making you not respect them?
Mm.
It's your ego.
It's your ego that makes you not respect people because you think,
oh,
I'm better than them.
I should have their job.
They don't know what they're talking about.
And I do.
That's all ego,
right?
So put your ego in check and just be like,
okay,
this person's above me.
They seem really inexperienced,
but what can I learn from them?
How did they get there?
If they're so dumb and bad at this job,
how come they outrank me?
Let me learn something from them.
Put your ego in check and this is the key point and anytime I talk about quote
unquote leading up the chain of command,
I will talk about this,
that no matter what boss I work for and I work for every different kind of boss,
Egomaniac,
psychopaths,
wonderful guys,
intelligent guys,
brilliant guys,
tacticians I worked for every different kind of boss and I always had the same
relationship with all of them.
That was my job was to build that relationship and that was a relationship of
high trust.
So they trusted me.
They're going to stay out of my way and let me do what I wanted,
and that's how you win.
Which by the way,
when you win,
they should never know you when they shouldn't even know that there was a
competition happening and that way you can do what you want.
And so that is how you deal with people above you and the chain of command that
you have little respect for or that lead from a place of ego.
You build a relationship with them.
You don't go head to head with them.
You're not gonna win and going head to head with your boss.
They're your boss.
They have rank on you.
If they're an EGOMANIAC,
they're going to use that rank.
If there's someone that you don't respect,
you got to build a relationship with them.
If there's someone that's an Egomaniac,
you got to build really,
regardless of the situation,
the solution is the same.
Build the relationship of trust,
help them build them up,
take a backseat,
let them get credit.
It's all those things,
and once you do that,
you're going to have,
you're going to have much better results than if you try and bang heads with
them,
overcome them,
defeat them,
have an antagonistic relationship with them.
It's never going to work.
So play the game.